un véritable bain de sang ce jeudi matin
dans une favela de la métropole de rio
une opération policière contre des
trafiquants de drogue a tourné à la
fusillade
une nouvelle tragédie pour les habitants
de ce quartier défavorisé
le gamin est arrivé blessé est ici dans
la favela
personne ne jette quelques uns de loire
il est resté ici et quand la police a vu
le sang elle est entrée en client ou est
similaire
j'ai juste eu le temps de mettre mes
enfants derrière moi et ils ont tué le
gamin dans la chambre je n'avais jamais
vu autant de sang il y en avait partout
dans la favela un manque de respect pour
la police scientifique
bref une absurdité totale les habitants
de la favela jacarezinho on rapportait à
la fp que des corps inanimés baigner
dans des mares de sang dans les ruelles
de nombreux cadavres ont ensuite été
placés dans un véhicule blindé de la
police présente sur place
lo ng réseau d'observatoires de la
sécurité publique dénonce des actes de
barbarie et rejette la faute sur le
nouveau gouverneur de l'état de rio de
janeiro
aujourd'hui les habitants ont vu leurs
maisons transformées en lieux de torture
où des gens ont été exécutés un garçon a
été exécuté et placé sur une chaise en
plastique au milieu de la rue le doigt
dans la bouche dans une pose moqueuse
pour que tout le monde puisse le voir le
gouverneur claudio castro qui est
officiellement en fonctions depuis cinq
jours défi le tribunal suprême fédéral
et la police de l'état est entré dans la
favela pour se livrer à une
démonstration de force
cette opération de police sanglante
s'est déroulé en dépit d'un arrêt de la
cour suprême interdisant les raids
policiers dans les favelas durant la
pandémie
sauf circonstances exceptionnelles les
forces de l'ordre ont précisé que
l'action de ce jeudi faisait suite à une
enquête contre 21 membres du gang
commando rouge en conférence de presse
les chefs de la police ont assuré que
l'ensemble des protocoles d'usagé
d'armes à feu avaient été respectées une
précision qui intervient alors que la
première personne tuée lors de cette
opération était un policier
je tiens à préciser que la police n'agit
pas sous le coup de l'émotion
afin qu'il n'y ait aucun doute je
rappelle que pour mener une telle
opération
nous planifions beaucoup et nous suivons
de nombreux protocoles les trafiquants
de drogue que met une série de délits
concrètement deux mineurs pour
travailler dans le trafic de drogue
attaque de train et nous avons constaté
plusieurs incidents dont la communauté
de jacarezinho
le jeudi 6 mai 2021 fera date au brésil
cette intervention policière devient la
plus meurtrière de l'histoire de l'état
de rio de janeiro selon l'institut qui
garent ep groupe de réflexion
spécialiste de la sécurité du
développement
la police de rio est responsable du
décès de 453 personnes entre janvier et
mars 2021